[Music]  was the night before life day  in a galaxy far far away looking good  tree food decorations coming together  heroes were  to celebrate the day please be okay  please  be a cape that's a wrap for ray  adventure called and she thought it  would be fast wow  but there she found a key to the  galaxy's past  what are you doing this is so cool we've  seen my master  my master's master concentrate my  master's father  impressive my master's father's master  dipper or palpatine  i don't believe it uh you think maybe  you could put a shirt on  it's a key to travel for space and time  i will change to the future so sure are  you  less talky talky more fighty fighting  races  oh so cute  you thinking what i'm thinking music  in time of joy this is ray a friendship  a family  who are you guys master skywalker my son  i mean my these binary sons  you want to shoot first after you  you